[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zur Sallys Welt!
Unsere kleine Ela-Maus, die wird schon fünf Jahre alt.
Da merkt man immer, wie schnell die Zeit rennt.
Und wir haben schon lange
über ihren Geburtstag gesprochen und über die Torte.
Natürlich gibt es ja jedes Jahr eine tolle Geburtstagstorte.
Und zuerst hat sie sich eine Fuchstorte gewünscht.
Und ich habe mich echt mega darauf gefreut.
Und dann kam so kurz vor knapp noch:
"Mama, ich will doch Peppa Wutz."
Also gibt es heute eine Peppa-Wutz-Torte.
Und die Torte mache ich so,
dass ihr sie wirklich supereinfach nachmachen könnt.
Und Ela hat sich dieses Motiv gewünscht
von Peppa Wutz.
Also nicht Peppa Wutz in dem roten Kleid im Matsch,
sondern Peppa Wutz als Fee.
So taucht sie auch ganz oft auf.
Und ich werde jetzt zuerst mal
einfach einen Blechkuchen herstellen
und danach das Ganze eben dekorieren.
Und die einzelnen Bestandteile sind echt supereinfach.
Ich muss auch dazu sagen,
da experimentiere ich geschmacklich nicht groß rum.
Denn Ela möchte einfach eine Erdbeertorte.
Und wir backen noch mal separat mit ihr zusammen
eine Schokotorte, so eine richtige Matschtorte.
Aber, wie gesagt, hier einfach Richtung Erdbeere.
Was ich jetzt allerdings machen werde:
Ich werde jetzt einfach einen Rührkuchen machen.
Und beim Rührkuchen könnt ihr einfach
eine Flüssigkeit nehmen,
Buttermilch, Mineralwasser oder einen Saft.
Und ich nehme jetzt einfach einen Sauerkirschsaft,
weil der auch schon mal die Farbe des Teigs verändert.
Für den Rührteig verwende ich
vier Eier,
– die sind bereits zimmerwarm –
eine Prise Salz,
200 Gramm Zucker,
jeweils 200 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl und Flüssigkeit,
– ich habe jetzt hier Kirschsaft –
400 Gramm Mehl
und ein Päckchen Backpulver.
Und wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr den Teig noch einfärben
mit etwas Farbpaste in Rosa oder Pink,
wenn ihr wollt.
Also ich mache jetzt erst mal kurz den Teig,
dass der schon mal rühren kann.
Und dann erkläre ich euch und zeige euch,
wie es hier dann weitergeht.
Ihr könnt jetzt mit dem Handrührgerät arbeiten
oder einfach mit der Küchenmaschine,
so, wie ihr möchtet.
Jetzt nehme ich einfach die Eier
und die werden mit dem Zucker und Salz und
– ja, hoppala, wo ist denn mein Vanilleextrakt?
Die Eier werden mit Zucker, Salz und Vanilleextrakt
für mindestens 10 bis 15 Minuten
schaumig verrührt.
Gut, dass ich noch einen Vorrat habe.
[Musik]
Fertig!
Das ist so meine Vorlage.
Die brauche ich gleich.
Hier ist die Eier-Zucker-Masse auch perfekt verrührt.
Jetzt kann ich hier die Flüssigkeiten zugeben.
Wie gesagt, nehme ich auch gerne Buttermilch
oder Sprudel.
Zack!
Kurz einrühren.
Und wenn ihr möchtet,
gerne
– man sieht es ja schon, es wird schon schön rosa.
Aber ich denke, so ein bisschen rosa Farbe brauche ich noch.
[Musik]
Und das Mehl und das Backpulver
werde ich jetzt so noch einrühren.
Ich habe jetzt hier so ein feines Mehl.
Deswegen siebe ich es auch nicht.
Das Backpulver klumpt nicht.
Aber im Normalfall bitte einfach dazu sieben.
Kurz einrühren.
[Musik]
Ich denke 30 mal 25 cm
ist eine gute Größe.
Und da fülle ich jetzt den Teig rein.
Falls ihr keinen Backrahmen habt,
könnt ihr auch einfach ein ganz normales Backblech benutzen,
auf dem ganzen Blech verteilen.
So habe ich aber einfach schon mal so ungefähr die Größe,
die ich später brauche.
Wir schneiden ja den Kuchen später sowieso zu.
[Musik]
Oh, das sieht so schön aus!
So. Jetzt kurz glatt streichen.
Und dann direkt im vorgeheizten Backofen backen,
bis der Kuchen gar ist.
Und ich werde in der Zwischenzeit schon mal
mich um den Untergrund kümmern
und auch um die Erdbeer-
– um den Erdbeergeschmack,
also um die Erdbeereinlage sozusagen.
[Musik]
Beim Kuchen immer einfach so an der höchsten Stelle
einstechen.
Aber der ist gut.
Da hängt nichts mehr dran.
Perfekt!
[Musik]
Ich verwende jetzt keine Marmelade.
Eine gekaufte wäre eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Da gibt es ja auch echt gute.
Ich habe jetzt nur gedacht, ich mache die Marmelade selber.
Denn dann kann ich den Zuckeranteil einfach reduzieren,
weil das Ganze ja schon eine Fondanttorte wird.
Und ich möchte einfach immer
so wenig Zucker wie möglich in der Torte haben,
weil eben die Fondantschicht schon sehr zuckrig ist.
Deswegen habe ich hier tiefgefrorene Erdbeeren.
Die gibt es ja momentan nicht regional und saisonal.
Daher einfach TK-Ware benutzen.
Ich habe jetzt hier 600 Gramm ungefähr.
Ein bisschen Zitronensaft kommt dazu,
ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt
und 50 Gramm Zucker.
Also es ist echt eine ganz kleine Menge Zucker.
Die Erdbeeren habe ich schon ein bisschen antauen lassen.
Und dann kommt einfach alles gemeinsam
in den Topf.
Und ich lasse es dann einkochen,
zerdrücke es hier ein bisschen mit dem Whacker.
Ihr könnt es auch pürieren, wenn ihr wollt.
Und einfach schön einkochen lassen,
damit wirklich fast die gesamte Flüssigkeit verschwindet
und ich später einfach eine schöne Marmelade habe,
die eben nicht zu wässrig ist.
[Musik]
Die Marmelade ist jetzt schön eingekocht.
Und hier riecht es echt wunderbar lecker!
Guckt mal. Ich fülle die jetzt auch direkt um.
Wenn ihr keine Stückchen haben wollt,
wie gesagt, entweder pürieren
oder durch ein Sieb passieren.
Das geht auch.
Aber ich lasse die Stückchen jetzt einfach mit dabei,
decke das Ganze ab und lasse sie schön abkühlen.
Und ich glaube, das ist echt so eine Marmelade,
die mir auch besonders gut schmeckt,
weil sie eben nicht so süß schmeckt.
So. Dann lasse ich das abkühlen.
Der Kuchen kühlt ab.
Wir essen unser Porridge.
Und dann geht es weiter.
[Musik]
Ich werde die Torte später
mit einer Buttercreme füllen und überziehen.
Ihr könnt auch eine Ganache machen.
Buttercremes habe ich ja auch schon
einige auf meinem Kanal.
Also zum einen die italienische Buttercreme,
die Swiss Meringue Buttercreme,
die
– mh,
welche gibt es noch? –
die französische Buttercreme.
Die könnt ihr alle machen,
wenn ihr die Torte mit Fondant überzieht.
Die deutsche Buttercreme geht da nicht.
Und wie gesagt, entweder könnt ihr
eins der Rezepte nehmen
oder ihr könnt hier diese Buttercreme nehmen.
Ich muss jetzt sagen,
einfach aufgrund der Zeit nehme ich die Buttercreme.
Die ist auch wirklich
– die ist von Decocino und die ist echt super.
Zum einen schmeckt sie sehr gut
und zum anderen denke ich mir mittlerweile ganz ehrlich,
gerade bei Fondanttorten,
da hat man ja sowieso schon einen großen Aufwand.
Und klar, so eine Buttercreme ist auch mal schnell gemacht
mit Eiern aufschlagen.
Und die muss man ja auch erwärmen.
Aber so ist es wirklich noch mal ein bisschen schneller.
Deswegen mache ich das jetzt so kurz.
Da nehme ich nämlich einfach nur einen Beutel
von dem Pulver,
nehme etwas Wasser dazu und die weiche Butter.
Und das Ganze ist jetzt wirklich schnell gemacht.
Und zwar wird einfach
das Pulver mit dem Wasser verrührt,
muss dann 30 Minuten stehen
und später kann ich die Buttercreme fertigstellen.
Ich zeige euch halt gerne immer so alle Alternativen.
Und gerade bei so einer aufwendigeren Torte,
muss ich sagen, machen wir es für das Video
und auch so für mich einfach etwas schneller.
[Musik]
Und jetzt könnt ihr hier die weiche Butter
und die Creme einfach schön verrühren,
schön schaumig aufschlagen.
Und dann geht es direkt schon ans Kuchenbefüllen.
Wenn ihr wolltet,
könnt ihr die Creme jetzt auch noch einfärben.
Aber ich finde es jetzt schön,
wenn ich einen rosanen Kuchen habe,
die rote Erdbeermarmelade und die helle Creme.
Dann habe ich so ein bisschen Kontrast mit dabei.
Das finde ich gut.
Ich glaube, was auch mega geschmacklich gepasst hätte,
wäre auch eine Schoko-Ganache gewesen.
Aber ich muss sagen, hier ist Vanille schon...
Ach, Josh, ich weiß auch nicht.
Aber ich finde, so Vanille und Erdbeere passt halt
schon perfekt.
>> JOSH: Was?
>> SALLY: Aber weißt du auch warum?
Weil ich ja auch noch diesen Schlammkuchen machen will.
Und der wird ja der pure
– und der wird ja nur Schokolade.
Deswegen finde ich so Erdbeere und Vanille gut
und dann Schokolade
und Schokolade.
Also einfach verrühren.
[Musik]
Ich bin Peppa Wutz.
Das ist mein kleiner Bruder Schorsch.
Das ist Mama Wutz.
Und das ist Papa Wutz.
Peppa Wutz!
Di-di-di-di-dit,
di-di-di-di-dit!
[Grunzlaut]
Wie bei so einem Apfel, weißt, den du schälst,
versuche ich,
eine Linie,
eine Unendlichlinie zu machen.
>> JOSH: Machst du da noch so eine Fenstergirlande daraus?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich mache so ein Zahnbürstenbild daraus.
Ich nehme das als Schablone
und noch eine Zahnbürste und Wasserfarbe.
Kennst du das noch?
>> JOSH: Also ich kann es mir vorstellen,
aber ich habe es noch nie gemacht.
>> SALLY: Dann hast du das so gemacht.
Und dann
nimmst du jetzt so Farbe auf mit der Zahnbürste
und tust es so über so ein Sieb streichen.
Jetzt kann ich hier den kalten Boden herauslösen.
Ich hatte den jetzt auch noch kurz im Kühlschrank,
damit er wirklich einfach schön kalt ist,
damit er sich besser schneiden lässt.
Jetzt fragt sich jeder:
Warum nimmt sie einen runden Tortenretter
unter einen eckigen Kuchen?
Aber ich schneidet das gleich weg.
Und dann ist der runde einfach handlicher
für den Kühlschrank.
Das ist der einzige Grund.
Und jetzt werde ich hier
mithilfe meiner Peppa-Schablone
einmal den Kuchen ausschneiden.
[Musik]
Den Arm und die Beine aber aussparen.
Die mache ich später einfach aus Fondant.
Die sind nämlich viel zu filigran.
So.
Und den restlichen Kuchen
werde ich weiterverarbeiten zu kleinen Kügelchen.
Vielleicht habe ich ja später noch Creme übrig.
Das mache ich dann nachher.
Aber guck mal, wie luftig und locker der ist.
Jetzt schneide ich den Boden hier einmal durch,
ganz vorsichtig.
Und hier kommt jetzt
eine Schicht Buttercreme
und eine Schicht Marmelade rein.
[Musik]
Ich forme jetzt übrigens gerade
so einen kleinen Rand für die Marmelade.
Und ihr seht schon, der Kuchen, der ist richtig locker.
Man muss dazu sagen,
dass es wirklich einfacher ist,
einen festen Kuchen glatt zu bekommen
und zu modellieren und glatt zu streichen.
Aber ich will ja, dass meine Kuchen schmecken.
Und deswegen finde ich so einen lockeren Kuchen echt gut.
Aber ich finde, gerade so in amerikanischen Rezepten
sieht man das echt oft, dass sie den Kuchen
echt so perfekt gerade schneiden können.
Aber der ist mir dann halt echt immer ein bisschen zu fest,
muss ich sagen.
Und hier geht es.
Also es dauert zwar ein bisschen länger
so mit den Krümelchen dann,
aber ich kriege es auf jeden Fall glatt.
So. Dann nehme ich jetzt
die Marmelade.
Die kommt jetzt hier rein.
Die sollte einfach nicht an den Rand raus.
Sonst wird es nämlich auch wieder schwierig.
[Musik]
Jetzt könnte es auch noch die Freiheitsstatue sein.
>> JOSH: Ich dachte es mir auch eben.
>> SALLY: Schon so ein bisschen.
Und jetzt hier eine dünne Schicht Buttercreme drauf.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe jetzt echt von allem sehr viel übrig,
also sowohl Torte
als auch Creme
als auch Marmelade.
Aber ist gar nicht schlimm.
Ich mache danach aus den Resten, glaube ich,
echt noch so ein
– vielleicht so ein Glas-Schichtdessert.
Man braucht halt so ein bisschen
diesen Überschnitt vom Kuchen.
[Musik]
Also hier im ersten Schritt ist gar nicht wichtig,
dass die Torte jetzt glatt ist
oder dass es schon perfekt aussieht,
sondern es ist nur wichtig,
dass die Torte einmal komplett mit Creme umhüllt ist,
damit die Buttercreme einfach schon mal fest werden kann
und vor allem auch hier außen
diese Krümelchen gebunden werden können.
Guck mal. Gerade hier diese kleine Ecke
habe ich noch.
Zack!
Das ist halt nun echt schwierig
mit so einem ganz lockeren, weichen Kuchen.
Aber ich gebe das jetzt so erst mal in den Kühlschrank,
lasse die Creme fest werden,
kann hier aufräumen
und mich schon mal um den Untergrund kümmern.
Da könnt ihr echt die Zeit immer prima nutzen.
[Musik]
Ich habe mir hier als Kuchenuntergrund
– nicht ich, sondern der Josh
hat mir einfach hier ein Holzbrett zugesägt.
Ich habe es sauber gemacht.
Und das nehme ich jetzt als Untergrund.
Ihr könnt aber auch,
wenn ihr sagt, ihr seid wirklich mehr Personen,
– wenn es die Regelungen zulassen,
seid ihr mehr Personen –
dann könnt ihr auch einen großen Kuchen backen
und sozusagen den Hintergrund,
also das Ganze, was ich jetzt auf Holz mache,
ihr könnt den Hintergrund als Blechkuchen backen
und dann eben Peppa noch obendrauf setzen.
Dann habt ihr so einen Doppelkuchen.
Aber für uns reicht jetzt wirklich so ein Minikuchen.
Daher mache ich den Hintergrund
einfach nur hier drauf aus Fondant.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein bisschen Hellblau für den Himmel,
Grün und Braun für den Matsch,
Grün natürlich für die Wiese
und rolle das hier jetzt dünn aus
und werde es dann einfach hier draufkleben.
Und dann habe ich schon mal eine schöne Platte.
[Musik]
Ich streiche jetzt hier so ein bisschen essbaren Kleber drauf.
Ihr könnt auch Wasser verwenden.
Aber der Kleber, der hält das Ganze
jetzt erst mal ein bisschen besser.
[Musik]
So. Dann einfach drüberlegen.
So.
Guckt einmal.
Und dann schön glatt gestrichen.
Und dann kommt hier jetzt so ein Streifen Grün
und ein bisschen Braun.
Und ich schneide es gleich mit dem Modelliermesser weg.
Aber das zeige ich euch.
[Musik]
So. Die zweite Farbe lege ich jetzt hier an.
Und dann einfach
beim Übergang eine schöne Linie zeichnen.
Ich glaube, ich mache sie tatsächlich so ein bisschen
gebogen.
[Musik]
Oh! Es fehlt ein bisschen Hellblau.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Denn Fondant kann man ja ganz gut in Form ziehen.
Guckt mal. Jetzt kann ich hier drunter nämlich
das wegnehmen.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, ich will jetzt nur kurz tatsächlich einmal
mit so einem Modellierwerkzeug
über die Kante gehen.
[Musik]
So. Und jetzt noch die Matschepfütze.
Peppa Wutz wäre ja nicht Peppa Wutz
ohne eine Matschepfütze.
Denn Peppa Wutz liebt Matschepfützen.
Alle lieben Matschepfützen.
[Musik]
Ja.
Ich habe die perfekte Möglichkeit gefunden,
diese kleinen Schlammspritzer zu machen.
Und zwar formt ihr den Fondant zu so kleinen Kügelchen.
Dann zu einem Tropfen.
Flach drücken.
Und dann
habt ihr einen Schlammtropfen.
[Musik]
Die Matschtropfen,
die klebe ich jetzt allerdings noch nicht fest.
Auch hier den Matsch noch nicht.
Das mache ich später.
Ich mache hier noch mal kurz sauber.
Und dann geht es wieder mit der Torte weiter.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehmt ihr die restliche Creme,
streicht die Torte schön glatt.
Achtet auch wirklich darauf,
dass gerade hier die Kanten schön glatt sind,
damit man später den Fondant eben gut drüber bekommt
und der dann nicht wellig wird, sondern schön aufliegt.
Was ist denn das für eine Handbewegung?
Ich nehme auch einfach ab und zu die Schablone,
lege sie noch mal drauf,
gucke, wo ich es einfach
noch ein bisschen präziser machen kann.
Und gerade so diese Kanten sind schon wichtig,
also, dass man später eben auch gut die Form erkennt.
[Musik]
[Geräusche aus dem Abfluss]
Ah!
Hast du jetzt nicht erwartet, hä?
>> JOSH: Nee.
[Geräusche aus dem Abfluss]
>> SALLY: Das macht mir jetzt wirklich Angst.
Also jetzt strecke meine Hand nicht mehr rein.
Und jetzt weiß ich auch,
wo der eigenartige Geruch herkommt.
Ich habe vorhin echt gedacht, hier hätte jemand gepupst.
Aber das kommt aus dem Abfluss.
[Musik]
Jetzt wird die Torte mit Fondant überzogen.
Und ich mache das jetzt so,
dass ich die einzelnen Abschnitte überziehe.
Das heißt, ich habe hier einmal ein helles Rosa für den Kopf,
Pink für den Körper
und Weiß für die Flügel.
Gelb brauche ich später noch für die Krone.
Ich muss auch echt sagen,
dass ich heute die Torte nicht ganz fertig bekomme.
Denn wir haben zwischendurch
echt noch viele andere Dinge gemacht.
Und ich werde sie jetzt einfach nur noch kurz überziehen
und dann morgen fertig dekorieren.
Ja.
Und vielleicht kann man da dazu sagen, dass
Fondanttorten im Kühlschrank
nicht abgedeckt werden sollten,
weil sie eben ansonsten schwitzen können
und der Fondant weich wird.
Aber, wenn ich andere Torten habe ohne Fondant,
decke ich die immer ab im Kühlschrank.
Also jetzt so die Buttercremetorte ohne Abdeckung
würde ich jetzt nicht lassen.
Aber der Fondant ist er ja dann sozusagen die Abdeckung
und die Schutzschicht.
[Musik]
So. Da ist sie, die kleine Peppa Wutz.
Ich hatte vorhin noch mal die
Vorlage draufgelegt zum Abgleichen.
Und ich werde das jetzt so machen:
Ich schneide die jetzt auseinander.
Und dann kann ich jetzt
die einzelnen Teile nämlich überziehen
und immer den Überschuss wegschneiden.
[Musik]
Das ist jetzt, muss ich sagen, so eine kleine
Fummelarbeit.
Aber es wird sich später lohnen.
Also macht ruhig immer richtig schön
so die Ecken und Kanten richtig,
die Übergänge.
Ihr seht auch schon, die Buttercreme,
die wird nicht so fest wie Ganache.
Also, wenn ihr es euch echt leicht machen wollt,
arbeitet mit Ganache.
Aber ich finde so eine Buttercreme einfach leckerer
als so eine feste Schokocreme.
Es ist beides lecker, muss ich sagen,
aber jetzt bei dem
fand ich das so schon leckerer.
Und hier könnt ihr so ein bisschen mit den Fingern
auch so noch die Ecken formen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier noch die Krone überzogen.
Ich muss echt sagen, mir ist gerade die Buttercreme
ein bisschen zu weich geworden.
Deswegen wurde das gerade ein bisschen problematisch.
Ich kühle die Torte jetzt bis morgen.
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich mache sie heute nicht fertig.
Und morgen setze ich mich an die Deko.
[Musik]
Gut.
Neuer Tag, neues Glück.
Jetzt kommt die Dekoration von Peppa Wutz.
Und dafür habe ich jetzt wieder
den Fondant bereits weich geknetet.
Da könnt ihr gern auch so ein bisschen Kokosfett nehmen.
Denn jetzt sollte der Fondant noch ein bisschen weicher sein.
Ich möchte jetzt nämlich diese Umrandungen machen.
Und entweder formt ihr jetzt daraus
so kleine, feine Umrandungen
– solche,
aber als langen Strang, um hier die Konturen zu legen –
oder ihr nehmt dafür
so eine Fondantpresse.
Da habe ich es gleich ein bisschen einfacher.
Und hier vorne habe ich so eine Scheibe drauf, eine runde.
Also die Umrandung jetzt auch nicht zu dünn machen.
Denn so filigran muss es gar nicht sein.
Dann hier
die weiche Fondantrolle rein.
Und jetzt einfach durch eine Drehbewegung
die Rolle rausdrücken.
[Musik]
Dann hier noch ein bisschen Weiß ausrollen für die Augen.
Und für die Augen nehme ich einfach
so eine Tülle zum Ausstechen.
Man muss auch sagen, Peppa Wutz hat ja
ein ziemlich lustiges Gesicht.
Denn sie hat beide Augen auf einer Gesichtshälfte.
Es fällt einem so beim Zugucken immer nicht so ganz auf,
aber dann
sieht es seltsam aus.
Dann noch Pink für die Wange.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen essbaren Kleber
und streiche den hier direkt an die Kontur.
Und da kann ich dann das Ganze schön befestigen.
[Musik]
Seid beim Kleber auch immer recht sparsam.
Der ist nämlich total ergiebig.
Also wirklich immer nur eine kleine Menge.
Ha! Jetzt erkennt man sie schon, die kleine Peppa Wutz.
[Musik]
Ihr könnt auch immer hier die Schablone benutzen
für die verschiedenen Größen,
also jetzt gerade hier so für den Mund zum Beispiel.
Und dann habt ihr proportional alles immer richtig gleich groß.
[Musik]
Hallo!
>> ELA: Hier. So hat der gelacht.
>> SALLY: Echt? Wie?
Zeig es mal dem Josh.
Wie hat der Yoshi gelacht?
[Trommelwirbel]
>> ELA: Aha!
>> SALLY: Eigentlich wollte ich dich
morgen damit überraschen.
>> ELA: Ich will aber mitmachen.
>> SALLY: Mh.
>> ELA: Bitte!
Ich wollte so gern mitmachen!
Bitte, Mami!
Ich wasche mir jetzt meine Hände eben.
Peppa-Wutz-Seife!
Yay!
Ups.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Backen wir gleich noch einen Schlammkuchen?
Weil Peppa Mutz
– Peppa Schmutz, Matschepfützen liebt?
>> ELA: Mama,
weißt du, was ich mir eigentlich vorgestellt habe?
>> SALLY: Was?
>> ELA: So eine Peppa-Wutz-
Erde.
>> SALLY: Eine Peppa-Wutz-Erde?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wie?
>> ELA: Dass es aussieht wie Peppa Wutz
und hier Matschepfütze drauf ist,
weil sie auf Matschepfützen gesprungen ist.
>> SALLY: Okay, das mit den Matschepfützen,
das können wir noch hinkriegen.
Aber du wolltest ja Peppa Wutz als Fee, gell?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ist sie eine Zahnfee?
>> ELA: Nein!
Eine ganz normale Fee!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> ELA: Und wo soll ich jetzt meine Hände abtrocknen?
Das da oder das da?
>> SALLY: Mh, das rote.
>> ELA: Und jetzt will ich dir mithelfen.
>> SALLY: Und deine Schürze noch tragen, gell?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Warte. Guck mal da. Da vorne, Ela.
Da vorne an der Seite.
Hä? Mama, ist das meine Schürze?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Hä? Wo ist sie denn?
Wie schnell ist das kaputt!
Und das war außen.
>> SALLY: Sag mal, Ela, kann das sein,
dass du heute ein kleiner Engel bist?
>> ELA: Ja.
Aber ich werde jetzt alles ausziehen vom Engel.
>> SALLY: Bist du dann kein Engel mehr?
Bist du dann ein Teufelchen?
>> ELA: Nein.
Ich bin ein ganz normaler Mensch dann.
>> SALLY: Ein ganz normaler Mensch?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ah, okay.
>> ELA: Wie du.
>> SALLY: So wie ich? Bin ich auch ein normaler Mensch?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Man munkelt, Menschen...
>> ELA: Jeder ist ein normaler Mensch.
Außer die Zahnfeen.
>> SALLY: Ja? Sind die keine normalen Menschen,
die Zahnfeen?
>> ELA: Nein.
Das sind keine normalen Menschen.
>> SALLY: Und was sind das?
>> ELA: Normale Menschen haben doch keine Flügel.
>> SALLY: Ach so! Stimmt.
Und eine Zahnfee hat Flügel, gell?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ah!
>> ELA: Und eine ganz normale Fee.
>> SALLY: So.
Ja, dann komm mal her.
Dann schieb mal den Hocker hierhin.
>> ELA: Okay. Ich will dir helfen.
Aus was ist der Kuchen?
Welche Zutaten hast du benutzt?
>> SALLY: Ich habe Erdbeeren benutzt.
>> ELA: Oh!
>> SALLY: Und Vanille-
>> ELA: Lecker!
>> SALLY: Und Vanillecreme.
Das hört sich so lecker an, Mama!
Yay!
>> SALLY: Yay!
>> ELA: Mama, ich mache die Matschepfützen bereit.
>> SALLY: Ja, mach die mal bereit.
Die hast sie nämlich schon entdeckt und wollte sie essen.
>> ELA: Nein!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> ELA: Ich wollte die gar nicht essen.
Ich möchte ja so was ganz anderes.
>> SALLY: Aber lass die Matschepfütze, Schatz.
Die brauchen wir.
>> ELA: Nein!
Die machen wir dann
>> SALLY: So die Augen.
>> ELA: hier drauf.
>> SALLY: Nein, nein, warte.
Ich habe noch was anderes für dich.
Das hast du noch gar nicht gesehen.
>> ELA: Wir brauchen doch
Augen!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Aber aus was machen wir die?
>> SALLY: Vielleicht auch aus Fondant?
>> ELA: Yay!
Fondanttorten!
>> SALLY: Josh, ich glaube, wir können mit Ela
einfach so einen Fondanttortenwerbeclip machen.
>> ELA: Yay! Fondanttorten!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Die Beine, die können wir gleich
aus der Fondantmaschine rausdrücken.
>> ELA: Aus welcher Fondant-
>> SALLY: Ich zeige dir jetzt mal die Fondantmaschine, okay?
>> ELA: Hm.
Ich habe noch nie eine Fondantmaschine gesehen.
Oh!
Mama?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> ELA: Kannst du auf meine bitte eine Fünf machen?
>> SALLY: Auf deine Torte?
Ja, klar.
Du wirst ja auch fünf Jahre alt.
>> ELA: Nein, mach eine Zwei lieber.
Das sieht so süß aus.
Und schreib da das hin, was das
ist.
>> SALLY: Ich schreibe bei dir "Ela" drauf.
>> ELA: Nein, schreib das hin.
>> SALLY: Da steht: "Peppa Wutz".
>> ELA: Ja, trotzdem.
Schreib "Peppa Wutz" bitte drauf.
Schreib "Schorschi und Peppa Wutz" drauf.
Mit Zuckerschrift!
Oh!
Okay.
Zuckerschrift ist doch keine gute Idee.
[Musik]
Mama, wie kriegt man diesen Fondant da?
>> SALLY: Ja, da musst du kurz auf Mama warten.
Weißt du, was Geduld bedeutet?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> ELA: Man muss warten.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Kannst du das?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Guck. Jetzt sieht die Krone noch besser aus, nicht?
>> ELA: Oder weißt du nicht mehr, als ich mal
– als ich mal auf dich gewartet habe oben?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: In meinem Zimmer.
>> SALLY: Ja, da, habe ich auch gesagt,
musst du mal fünf Minuten Geduld haben, gell?
>> ELA: Ja.
Und jetzt habe ich auch fünf Minuten Geduld.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Guck. Sieht das so cool aus?
>> ELA: Ja!
Aber wir brauchen noch mehr Fondant.
Du weißt ja
– guck mal!
Die Punkte fehlen doch noch.
>> SALLY: Ja, die Punkte machen wir noch.
>> ELA: Ach.
Aber die da, die Krone,
die ist nur blau und pink.
Halt. Du darfst nicht.
Halt, Mama.
>> SALLY: Guck. Das sieht doch süß aus.
>> ELA: Aber...
>> SALLY: So. Hast du Pink?
Nee, das ist Rosa, was du hast.
>> ELA: Oh!
>> SALLY: Hier ist Pink. Schau mal.
>> ELA: Hm.
Darf ich das Pink machen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ausrollen.
Ah! Ela, warte.
Du hast gerade die Torte fast
kaputt gerollt.
So.
Jetzt mit dem ausstechen.
>> ELA: Ich will.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Warte kurz. Da ist ein...
Guck mal. Da ist so ein Streifen
drin. Aber okay...
>> ELA: Mama?
Darf ich mal auch kleben?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Die Torte ist jetzt erst mal so weit fertig dekoriert.
Die kommt noch mal in den Kühlschrank.
Ich muss halt echt sagen,
dass bei Buttercreme der Nachteil ist,
die Butter wird eben bei Raumtemperatur
eben auch recht schnell warm.
Das heißt, die Torte wird jetzt auch wieder weich.
Da ist wirklich eine Ganache besser,
aber geschmacklich, wie gesagt, die Buttercreme.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Die kommt in den Kühlschrank.
Und dann machen wir den Untergrund.
Denn ich zeige dir das mal.
Das habe ich schon vorbereitet.
>> ELA: Dann kann ich schon mal probieren.
>> SALLY: Fondant.
Jetzt geht es mit dem Tortenuntergrund weiter.
Und da schreibe ich jetzt drauf: "Happy Birthday, Ela!",
auf einem blauen Untergrund und rosa Schrift
so wie bei Peppa Wutz eben.
Also hier ein bisschen Fondant ausrollen.
Das darf ruhig so ein bisschen wolkig aussehen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt nehme ich hier diese Buchstabenprägestempel.
Denn die sind richtig cool.
Damit kann ich jetzt hier Rosa einmal ausstechen.
Dann kommt da ein bisschen Kleber oder Wasser drauf.
Und dann kann man das hier
mit einem leichten Druck draufsetzen
und so einprägen.
[Musik]
Und hier solltet ihr einfach darauf achten,
dass die zweite Farbe auch nicht zu dünn ausgerollt wird.
Weil jetzt ist es so ein bisschen schwierig
– denn normalerweise drückt man die Buchstaben
direkt in eine Torte ein –
dadurch, dass ich jetzt hier
auch keinen festen Untergrund habe.
Es ist ein bisschen Übungssache, aber es funktioniert.
Moment.
Das P.
Aber, wie gesagt, nicht zu dünn ausrollen.
>> ELA: Aha!
Du hast ohne mich angefangen!
Warum hast du mich nicht gefragt?
>> SALLY: Ja, Entschuldigung? Du bist einfach abgehauen.
[Musik]
Schatzi!
Schatz, die Blau brauche ich noch.
>> ELA: Warum?
Aber die brauche ich doch auch.
Bitte, Mama. Ich nehme mir nur was für den Nektar.
>> SALLY: Welcher Nektar?
>> ELA: Du weißt doch, der Nektar
für die Blume.
>> SALLY: Okay.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Ups.
>> SALLY: Kann es sein, dass mein Fondant
hier gerade immer weniger wird?
>> ELA: Was?
>> SALLY: Weil ihn jemand aufisst?
>> ELA: Was ist das für ein Buchstabe?
>> SALLY: Da steht: "Happy Birthday, Ela!"
Ich lege das hier mal hin.
Denn ich würde sagen,
ich mache noch ein paar Wimpelketten.
Oder? Wimpelketten sind immer schön, gell?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann
holen wir die Torte, legen sie drauf
und dann die Deko.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Hm?
Guck mal. Wimpelketten macht man so, Ela.
[Musik]
So. Ich ziehe jetzt schon mal
die Peppa-Wutz-Torte hier drauf, ja?
>> ELA: Auf das?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Oh!
Warum?
>> SALLY: Ja, auf den Untergrund.
>> ELA: Wow! Das sieht sogar richtig gut aus,
die Peppa-Wutz-Schlange.
Ich bin gleich fertig, Mama.
>> SALLY: Gut.
>> ELA: Aber da
dieses Messer wird doch für die Knete benutzt.
>> SALLY: Ja, das kannst du auch für Fondant und für Knete
und für Marzipan,
für Teig, für alles benutzen.
So. Jetzt habe ich ja die Torte umgesetzt.
Und jetzt mache ich hier drumherum
einmal eine Umrandung mit Weiß,
einfach, dass es schön sauber aussieht.
Warte, warte, warte.
Das habe ich gerade für mich freigeräumt.
Das brauche ich mal ganz kurz.
Du kriegst es gleich.
>> ELA: Was ist das?
>> SALLY: Da ist bisschen Kuchen.
>> ELA: Lecker!
>> SALLY: Peppa-Wutz- Kuchen.
>> ELA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Erdbeerkuchen.
>> ELA: Es schmeckt eigentlich richtig gut.
>> SALLY: Ja?
Hast du schon mal einen Kuchen von Mama gegessen,
der nicht geschmeckt hat?
Jetzt muss sie aber lange überlegen.
Hast du schon mal einen Kuchen gegessen von mir,
der nicht geschmeckt hat?
>> ELA: Alle Kuchen schmecken von dir.
[Oh-Rufe]
>> SALLY: Ich hatte kurz Angst,
weil du so lange überlegt hast.
Ich habe gedacht, dir schmeckt es dann vielleicht nicht.
Aber da bin ich ja voll beruhigt.
Sollen wir uns dann noch Spiele überlegen
für deinen Geburtstag?
>> ELA: Ja!
Mama!
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> ELA: Wir brauchen alles, was für eine Piñata ist.
>> SALLY: O nein.
>> ELA: Eine Piñata!
Yay!
>> SALLY: Ich habe gedacht, sie hat es vergessen.
>> ELA: Bitte!
Eine Peppa-Wutz-Piñata!
>> SALLY: Ach so, eine Peppa-Wutz-Piñata?
Und wer soll die basteln?
>> ELA: Wir basteln sie nicht, wir bestellen sie.
>> SALLY: Ach, so was gibt es?
>> ELA: Mama!
>> SALLY: O nein.
Was ist aus meiner weißen Umrandung geworden?
>> ELA: Ein Pappkarton.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, die Ela hatte hier
ein paar grüne Farben drin.
>> ELA: Und Rosa.
Rosa und Grün mag ich.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß auch nicht, ob es mir gefällt.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Mama, was würdest du nehmen?
Weiß oder Rosa?
>> SALLY: Mh.
Weiß.
>> ELA: Aber ich würde Rosa nehmen.
>> SALLY: Ich nehme jetzt hier noch weiße Zuckerschrift.
>> ELA: Na toll! Jetzt
>> SALLY: Was denn?
>> ELA: ist es nicht mehr schön.
>> SALLY: Ich mache jetzt hier eine Linie
für die Wimpelkette.
[Musik]
Die Beinchen werden jetzt rosa.
Die Schuhe werden pink.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, ich mache jetzt hier die Zahl Fünf, Ela.
Die machen wir einfach hier in Peppas Hand, okay?
Auf den Bauch.
>> ELA: Und warum ist hier eine Zahnbürste
eigentlich?
>> SALLY: Damit ich manchmal so Sachen
einfach wegputzen kann,
aber nicht auf meinen Zähnen, sondern auf den Torten.
Weißt du, wenn jetzt hier was liegt,
muss ich so ganz vorsichtig,
weil das ja so dickere Borsten hat als so ein Pinsel.
Und manchmal brauche ich einfach so
ein bisschen mehr Widerstand. Weißt du?
Guck mal!
>> ELA: Und was ist Widerstand?
>> SALLY: Was ist denn das für eine Zahl hier?
>> ELA: Eine Fünf.
>> SALLY: Und warum?
>> ELA: Weil ich fünf bin.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Jetzt ist die Torte fertig
und die Küche ist wieder geputzt, nicht?
Keine Schweinerei mehr hier.
Oder?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, die einzige Schweinerei ist hier,
die Matschepfütze bei Peppa Wutz, hä?
Und wie gefällt dir die Torte?
>> ELA: Gut.
>> SALLY: Gut.
Morgen machen wir noch Kerzen rein, okay?
>> ELA: Wo?
>> SALLY: Mh. Vielleicht
einfach hier auf die Flügelchen.
>> ELA: Nein! Sonst sieht es ja aus, als wenn die verbrennt.
>> SALLY: Oh, stimmt.
Das überlegen wir uns noch.
Also morgen...
>> ELA: Ah! Hier auf die Fünf!
>> SALLY: Stimmt.
Morgen werden wir die Torte dann essen.
Das heißt, das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr in diesem Video.
Aber vielleicht können wir ja
ein bisschen was aufnehmen, gell?
Ja?
Da können wir mal gucken, nicht?
Und das Rezept findet ihr auf?
>> ELA: sallys-blog.de.
>> SALLY: sallys-blog.de.
Viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Warte, warte.
Vielleicht sollte ich noch dazu sagen:
Die Torte ist echt im Prinzip supereinfach zu machen.
Aber, wenn ihr dran seid, wirklich so
vielleicht zwei, drei Stunden am Tag davor,
so dieses Füllen, Backen,
und zwei, drei Stunden danach zum Dekorieren.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Tschüss!
Weißt du was?
Du bist ein kleiner Quatschkopf.
Stimmt das?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Bist du ein Quatschkopf?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wer ist hier ein Quatschkopf?
Du bist eine kleine Peppa Wutz.
Und wie macht Peppa Wutz?
[Grunzlaute]
>> ELA: Und ich bin Peppa Wutz.
[Grunzlaut]
>> SALLY: Ich bin Mama Wutz.
[Grunzlaute]
[Grunzlaut]
[Musik]
>> ALLE: ... birthday to you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, liebe Ela!
>> ALLE: Bravo!
[Musik]